der mikrokosmos unendlich klein
wir schreiben das jahr 2015 dies sind
die abenteuer eines mikro noten der seit
zehn jahren unterwegs ist um neue welten
zu erforschen unbekanntes leben mitten
unter uns
viele lichtjahre vom sichtbaren entfernt
gibt es welten die nie zuvor ein mensch
gesehen hat der kosmos des micro noten
übernimmt darin die parasitische in
sektor wird flo
denn sind das show eigentlich monster
oder ich stell dir bewusst so dass man
durch die perspektive hat aus über
winzige vor sondereinflüssen stieg das
rasterelektronenmikroskop öffnet das tor
in die wundersame welt des mikrokosmos
besonders schön in die vietoris ist also
vielleicht 30 bis 50 metern angelegt bis
sie perfekt 6
das perfekte exemplar
sozusagen die heidi klum unter den
fluren
um sie und all die anderen possierlichen
tierchen in ihrer ganzen pracht zu
zeigen hat es monate gebraucht
hunderte von vierbeinern hat martin
eckerle abgrasen lassen um die perfekten
objekte seiner begierde zu finden andere
organismen sucht er selbst hier eine
bildserie über kräuter bis extrem fein
duftet hunderte exotisch duftenden
pflanzen gibt es im botanischen garten
basel ag entscheidet sich für
gewöhnliches basilikum ihn interessieren
die duftdrüsen
terra incognita für den micro 9
erholen die dort rufen sie doch könnten
doch könnten aber druck vom 7
wo er dem blatt suchen unter druck aber
eigentlich weiß aber doch keiner
wie das genau aussieht wenn man da mal
einer gut und böse in dem bericht von
der oberfläche in einer landschaft um
ähnlich sehen das
rasterelektronenmikroskop zeigt nur
zweidimensionale bilder und auch nur
schwarz weiß aber der mikro not kann
fast beliebig tief hinab tauchen in die
mikrostruktur von basilikum sieht das
aus wenn der flug über der landschaft
der hügellandschaft mit machu picchu
das schwarz-weiß-bild ist das
rohmaterial des micro noten die welt der
wissenschaft liegt hinter ihm
es beginnt der künstlerische teil seiner
arbeit martin oeggerli lässt sich jetzt
von fantasie und assoziationen leiten
also ich sag mir mal bilder von machu
picchu mehr einfach selber mal einen
überblick verschaffen was was für
stimmige geht es da überhaupt und
zusammen mit dem natürlichen vorab von
basilikum suche ich den eigentlichen
illusion inszenieren
martina kalli fügt nichts hinzu er
betont nur details wie blood haare oder
duftdrüsen
der vola basilikum aller machu picchu
martinelli veröffentlicht in großen
magazinen wie nature und national
geographic der chinesische künstler ai
wei wei hat seine bilder zu dem auch auf
der guangzhou design biennale gezeigt
wenn modernes design lässt sich gerne
inspirieren von organischen strukturen
meadows dass die wissenschaftlichkeit
vor der bilder die andere so dort extrem
im hintergrund rücken uns eigentlich
mehr und form und farbe gut
sobald das bild farbe gewählt und
inszeniert wird wieder bis
rheinhessischer wissenschaftlichen kunst
bild in der kunstausstellung inszeniert
die mundwerkzeuge eine mücken laufe
doch auch wenn man nicht genau weiß
worum es sich gerade handelt er schließt
sich die schönheit dieser welt
allein die nie gesehenen strukturen
formen und farben machen die
abenteuerreise in den mikrokosmos zu
einem ästhetischen genuss